die erste frage vielleicht an sie herr
klaus weltwirtschaftsforum in davos ganz
im zeichen dieses krieges seelands
gewillt schneller noch mehr waffen
habeck waren vor einer globalen
rezession
ursula von der leyen fordert die ukraine
wo es diesen krieg gewinnen und wir alle
haben noch den kanzler im ohr der sagte
die praline muss bestehen was
möglicherweise was anderes heißt das
heißt wie wird all das auf sie
naja was wir jetzt erkennen ist dass es
grundsätzliche fragen gibt die über die
aktuelle tagespolitik hinaus gehen
welches europa stellen sich politiker in
paris sehen brüssel und auch in berlin
eigentlich vor dass die ukraine heute
macht ist in den augen vieler
mitteleuropäer der beiden polen der
slowakei tschechien
die verteidigung von uns ein und die
unterstützung der ukraine wird in polen
der zweite besuch bereits von präsident
lula in kiew als die verteidigung
europas gesehen also wenn man davon
redet dass die ukraine gewinnen soll
dann sind das für diese verbündeten von
deutschland in der eu
existenzielle fragen und wenn man dann
hört
die widersprüchlichen signale aus berlin
dass man sich vielleicht um nicht nur
berlin auch paris und auch aus rom mario
draghi war sehr klar aber seine
koalitionspartner haben in den letzten
tagen matteo salvini silvio berlusconi
die alle teil der koalition in rom sind
angedeutet vielleicht diese
unterstützung für die ukraine nicht zu
übertreiben druck aufzubauen vielleicht
doch irgendeine art von waffenstillstand
und friede
auch auf kosten des territoriums der
ukraine dabei zu führen dann werden die
hälfte der eu nämlich die die an die
ukraine grenzen und die auf russland
blicken extrem nervös also die große
frage was in einem im 2 in fünf jahren
die beziehung zwischen der ukraine und
europa sein soll wie die ukraine dann
aussehen soll und ob man bereit ist
teile der ukraine zu opfern für
irgendeinen frieden die ist tatsächlich
hinter dieser oberflächlichen einigkeit
in der eu noch nicht gelöst sozusagen
berlusconi alter putin freund matthias
an ein alter freund
das heißt da diese viel beschworene
einigkeit und einheit die wieder gerade
die ganze zeit immer wieder einen
sonntagsreden aufgehört haben die brettl
da passiert gerade was auch in den usa
gibt sich debatten rund um die fragen
sollten wir weiterhin unbegrenzt waffen
an die ukraine liefern oder sollten wir
lieber nicht also es gibt legitime
debatten und es gibt gleichzeitig aber
auch in frankreich die parlamentswahlen
und viele der parteien die in frankreich
in den letzten monaten zusammen sehr
stark waren manager natürlich le pen
waren in der vergangenheit extrem nato
kritisch europa eu kritisch und russland
freundlich und es gab einen moment den
gibt es vielleicht noch ein paar
beweisen nicht wochen monate in dem die
europäische union noch gemeinsam
zusammen entsteht wenn es aber jetzt
nicht gelingt eine vision zu
präsentieren hinter der sich die eu
findet die aber dann auch zu etwas führt
etwa einer klaren einem kern angebot an
die ukraine zu sagen so wollen wir mit
euch weiter machen wenn das jetzt nicht
gelingt wo die zustimmung auch die
popularität der ukraine bei der
bevölkerung noch relativ hoch ist es
vergehen noch einige monate die
spannungen werden steigen die putin
freunde in der politik werden lauter und
dann besteht die große gefahr dass das
passiert was bis jetzt vermieden werden
konnte nämlich eine spaltung der
europäischen union bei einer für viele
staaten
existenziellen frage bei 7 7 grad in
moldau
was was haben sie dort erfahren wie
schauen die moldawier auf das was da
passiert na ja also wir haben die ich
habe immer das gefühl und mit osteuropa
anspricht die die fragen wo ist europa
wo seid ihr wo es vor allen dingen auch
deutschland also dieses sozusagen
christoph heusgen das glaube ich dieser
tage so formuliert immer nur das
nötigste und immer auf den letzten
drücker das ist das was sozusagen da
draußen von deutschland gerade ankommt
ist der eindruck richtig also mal da ist
ein großartiges beispiel für eine meiner
meinung nach viel zu zögerliche politik
der europäischen union und auch
deutschland
wir haben hier eine ein land das ärmste
land europas 2,6 millionen einwohner in
dem gebiet dass die regierung beherrscht
es gibt eine russische
ein eingefrorener konflikt mit
russischen truppen in transnistrien die
meisten flüchtlinge in der eu pro kopf
in neuler in diesem ärmsten land eine
proeuropäische reformregierung ich habe
viele der minister getroffen
beeindruckende
anti korruptions kampagnen haben sie an
die macht gebracht eine präsident den
außenminister eine innenministerin die
wirklich nach europa blicken und einen
beamten start starb der in den letzten
wochen intensiv fragen der europäischen
kommission beantwortet hat die ihnen
gestellt wurden weil sie sich um die
mitgliedschaft bewerben jetzt haben wir
ein kleines land das an rumänien
angrenzt und die einfache frage sie ist
aber fundamental ist bleibt die grenze
der eu und der nato auch die nächsten 30
jahre dieser grenzfluss der brut
zwischen rumänien und moldau
bleibt moldaus sowie die ukraine in
diesem geopolitischen niemandsland wo in
den letzten 30 jahren ununterbrochen
kriege ausgebrochen sind in
transnistrien in georgien in der ukraine
in karabach im kaukasus oder schaffen
wir es auf diesen wunsch dieser
bevölkerungen und der politischen eliten
kreativ zu antworten wenn man heute
fragt in berlin
warum gibt es noch zweifel jetzt
dieser republik moldau oder dieser
ukraine im juni den kandidatenstatus
zugeben als mit als möglicher als
mögliches mitglied der eu zu sagen ihr
seid ein kandidat was man 99 der türkei
gegeben hat was man mazedonien 2005
gegeben hat ein symbol aber ein klares
symbol wenn man es verweigert an putin
dass in europäischen union bei dieser
grundsatzfrage des signals die europäer
tief gespalten werden und ich verstehe
nicht wie man angesichts einer krise
jeder weiß wenn man dort destabilisiert
wird wenn dieses arme land unter der
last der wirtschaftlichen der der
steigende energiepreise des
wirtschaftlichen drucks der vielen
flüchtlinge der spannungen in der
nachbarschaft der geschlossene
hautmodell wo die ganzen exporte
traditionell hinausgegangen sei wenn
dieses land instabil wird die
flüchtlinge kommen zu uns also es
betrifft uns direkt es betrifft rumänien
es betrifft das ist ja das ist auch
interessant mit genau der erzählung mit
der jetzt auch schon propaganda gemacht
mit der erzählung wenn ihr uns weiter
unter druck setzt also von russischer
seite dann schicken wir flüchtlinge dann
müsst ihr zu sehen bilder mit den ganzen
leuten klar kommt es gibt es gibt glaube
ich einen historischen moment der der
vergleichbar ist mit mit den großen
entscheidungen der europäischen
geschichte nach dem zweiten weltkrieg 19
57 hat damals der europäische union
gesagt wir gründen die sechs länder die
damals die europäische
wirtschaftsgemeinschaft gegründet haben
aus der die europäische union hervor
gegen kriegen wir bauen die grenzen
zwischen uns ab das war vor dem
hintergrund dass wird heute vergessen
eines krieges den frankreich in algerien
geführt hat die schlacht von algier war
gleichzeitig zu den verhandlungen in
europa etwas einzigartiges zu schaffen
einen eine wirtschaftsgemeinschaft ohne
grenzen trotzdem hat damals konrad
adenauer als bundeskanzler seinen
eigenen wirtschaftsminister mit der
richtlinienkompetenz gezwungen zu sagen
und ihm gesagt wir wollen hier jetzt die
europäer mit einem gemeinsamen markt
zusammenbringen das ist politisch
wichtig und die frage ist jetzt schaffen
wir es heute schafft olaf scholz das was
damals konrad adenauer gemacht hat und
sagt wir wollen heute der ukraine moldau
und anderen demokratien ein ähnliches
angebot machen sie hineinzuholen in den
europäischen binnenmarkt die vier
freiheiten das was wir jetzt haben das
ukraine relations' kommen können zu
garantieren wir werden das nicht in ein
zwei jahren wieder aufheben europa
zusammenzubringen
vor dem hintergrund von krieg und
instabilität oder
lassen wir das im moment vorbei laufen
und sehen wir europa weiterhin gespalten
in eine zone der stabilität im westen
und eine zone in der in den letzten 30
jahren ständig träger gefunden das war
schon interessant was sich da gerade
aufbaut und es gibt leute auch wie wie
sigmar gabriel zum beispiel die sagen
wir laufen auf eine situation zu dass
wir wieder so einen richtigen eisernen
vorhang haben werden es gibt die auf der
einen und die auf der anderen seite und
wir werden uns bis an die zähne
bewaffnet gegenüberstehen und mit blick
auf zum beispiel schweden und auch
finnland stimmt das natürlich auch man
hat das gefühl auch in skandinavien ist
die nackte panik bricht er geradeaus wir
haben das verhalten finnlands und
schwedens und gerade schwedt nach 200
jahren der neutralität zu sagen wir
können diese neutralität als
verantwortungsbewusste politiker nicht
länger aufrechterhalten dieser dieses
zeichen dass wir in einem neuen kalten
krieg stehenden der so lange andauern
wird solange putin und sein regime im
kreml an der macht sind
bedeutet aber auch dass es kaum raum
gibt oder keinen raum mehr für länder in
diesem niemandsland die werden zu opfern
oder sie führen wie die ukraine jetzt
unter enormen opfern ständige kriege und
hier jetzt zu sagen wir nehmen diese aus
förderung konstruktiv an wir
mobilisieren die ressourcen europäischen
union schauen zurück in die geschichte
was funktioniert hat stabilisieren all
dieser demokratie das ist nicht nur
kurzfristig sondern mittelfristig die
einzige chancen dass aus dieser krise
mehr stabilität entsteht in russland
wird nichts unversucht lassen auf dem
balkan in moldau in der ukraine zu
versuchen diese staaten so zu zermürben
der zermürbungskrieg von dem jetzt alle
reden der die ukrainische wirtschaft
zerstören sollten reden wir gleich
darüber mit herrn kölmel genau da jetzt
eine klare antwort zu geben und zu sagen
wir sehen in europa wo in wenigen jahren
der der binnenmarkt die
bewegungsfreiheit die barrieren abgebaut
werden wo man da wo die ukraine wo auch
die bei kann demokratien dabei sind und
deutschland schaffte es hier die
interessen der polen und balten und
tschechen und slowaken mit den
interessen der niederländer und
franzosen in eine funktionierende eu zu
versöhnen mit einem vorschlag in diesem
moment wie dieses europa aussehen soll
und dieser historische moment ist jetzt
da und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob alle
in deutschland in der politik in der
koalition sich bewusst sind wie es
aussehen würde wenn jetzt deutschland
versucht bei dieser frage wer gehen wir
mit dem antrag auf mitgliedschaft der
der ukraine sich hinter den niederlanden
zu verstecken und zu sagen wir haben
hier keine klare position oder wir
machen das was unsere partner machen das
selber so die die lose und
ich weiß genau jetzt kommt ein anderer
guter bekannter erdogan nato zum
beispiel welches spiel spielt er hatte
in dem zusammenhang gesagt mehr russland
finnland und schweden in der nato das
sehe ich nicht das ist klassische
politik einerseits nach innen den
starken mann zu markieren die türkei und
gerade erdogan steht unter unglaublichem
druck die wirtschaftskrise in der türkei
ist tief die inflation ist enorm hoch
die jungen leute in der türkei haben
kaum eine perspektive die opposition hat
das migrations thema aufgegriffen und
greift er dann dafür dass so viele
syrische flüchtlinge im land sind und in
dieser situation versucht erdogan
einerseits abzulenken und andererseits
will er etwas dafür bekommen hall geht
es um ein paar milliarden mehr es geht
um waffe ich nehme an ich kann in seinen
einblicken aber er erfordert dinge von
den amerikanern er tut so als ginge es
dabei um politische flüchtlinge in
schweden er sagt ja dass in schweden
menschen die aus der türkei fliehen asyl
bekommen haben die erst error ehesten
bezeichnen aber ein land wie schweden
hat unabhängige gerichte die idee dass
die regierung hier menschen ausliefern
könnte ist absurd das wissen natürlich
auch die türkische regierung also ich
glaube das ist ein spiel um sich noch
einmal ins in den mittelpunkt der
debatte geht es einfacher da sich ja um
waffen geht es um die um die kampfjets
die haben also ich bin ganz sicher wenn
er sich mit den amerikanern da
zusammensetzt dann redet er nicht über
politische flüchtlinge in schweden
sondern dann gegenüber handgreiflich
suchen es geht am ende zu machen am ende
geht es darum dass die türkei versuche
etwas für sich herauszuholen und sich
als man hat gesehen in der reaktion in
den letzten zwei tagen nach der nato des
generalsekretärs der natürlich sehr
vorsichtig über die türkei spricht da
sagt wie wichtig ist wie wie bedeuten
dass nato partner das ist ein versuch
einen moment zu nutzen um eigentlich die
politische schwäche erdogans in der
türkei zu kaschieren
und ja die verbündeten unter druck zu
setzen da sehen wir gerade einen
stoltenberg frau tut der heute zitiert
wird mit dem satz freiheit sei wichtiger
als freihandel wie klingt das für
jemanden wie sie der sich so viele mit
globalisierung beschäftigt hat er sich
so für mit wirtschaft beschäftigt was
bedeutet all das also auch da auch schon
richtig ein historischer moment bisher
konnte man sich aber auf das verlassen
was medwedew auch dieser tage gesagt hat
konflikte kommen und gehen aber geld
bleibt darauf konnten sich die russen
verlassen auf dieses zynische
selbstverständnis aber das scheint
offensichtlich zuwandten das
funktioniert nicht mehr naja wir sehen
ja schon also freiheit klar freiheit hat
immer grenzen freihandel hat ohnehin
grenzen aber dass die wirtschaft auch
sieht welche man welche punkte er
momentan gelangt sind ist ja
offensichtlich also wie viele länder
haben sich aus russland zurückgezogen
also viel unternehmen aus
verschiedensten ländern oder auch wie
viele unternehmen halten ohne murren
sanktionen ein das ist sanktion ist ja
immer dass das länderregierungen
bestimmte regeln bestimmen was nicht
mehr möglich ist und unternehmen müssen
das aber einhalten und tragen dafür auch
die kosten also insofern ist das eine
weisheit die durchaus jetzt im moment
längst umgesetzt wird aber heißt das da
kommt so ein ganzes modell ein ganzes
system ist auch an sein ende also was
wir dieser tage häufig hören ist
globalisierung muss man darüber
nachdenken
das können wir so auf dauer nicht mache
dann kenne ich andere ökonomen die sagen
nein die antwort auf das kann eigentlich
nur mehr globalisierung sein weil wir
absolut nicht unabhängig autark werden
können wir brauchen die chinesen wir
brauchen die amerikaner das heißt
eigentlich müsste die antworten mehr
freihandel sein wenn wir uns abkapseln
dass wir gleich von ihnen auch hören
dann führt das vielleicht sogar dazu
dass wir am ende die über nahrungsmittel
engpässe sprechen auch in der
sogenannten westlichen welt wir sollten
über abhängigkeiten sprechen weil das
was wir im moment als freihandel
betreiben ist ja sehr stark fixiert auf
die billigsten preis und der landete
dann was energie angeht oft bei wenigen
ländern zum beispiel von deutschland aus
bat russland oder was sehr viele dinge
die in der deutschen industrie gefragt
sind china und das in einseitigkeiten
sehr schnell dann irgendwann teuer
werden können weil wir merken entweder
wird uns alles abgedreht oder mit der
korona pandemie sind die lieferketten
gebrochen das müsste nicht nur
regierungen zu umdenken wie sie
sicherheit organisieren bringen sondern
ich glaube das müsste auch unternehmen
schon längst dazu gebracht haben zum
beispiel auch zu sagen wo könnten wir
uns diversifizieren wo könnten wir
vielleicht auch mit ressourcen sparsam
umgehen mit rohstoffen sparsamer umgehen
und dann und eben weniger abhängig
halten sind wir als als land als
deutschland da gerade in einer
ziemlichen dilemma um mich zu sagen
miserablen situation was energie angeht
komplett abhängig von russland und was
den export angeht also import abhängig
von russland und was den export angeht
komplett abhängig von china
zwei systeme von dem wir gerade merken
wir spielen die eigene spiel zwei kinder
sind wir auch von importen deutlich
abhängig haben wir ja eine corona
pandemie ist man es gar nicht geben
unabhängig die nicht wirklich kompatibel
sind mit dem sache ja ich glaube es
umgekehrt euren druck schuss wenn wir
denken dass wir nur noch mit demokratien
handel werden treiben also da gibt es ja
auch schattierungen und wer kann sich
herausnehmen wo wir handel betreiben es
geht einfach darum zu überdenken
abhängigkeiten sind nie gut wir müssen
diversifizieren
unternehmen müssen auch diversifizieren
die können kein interesse daran haben
zum beispiel jetzt mit china sind bei
den jetzt wieder informationen heraus
gekommen wie schlimm ein system eine
volksgruppe unterdrückt bis zur
auslöschung womöglich da kann kein
unternehmen ein interesse daran haben
dass es vielleicht sogar zulieferungen
bekommt die in zwangslagen oder
sonstiger gestellt sind also insofern
muss das selbst interesse das
miteinbeziehen und
bedeutet dann eben auch ja schaut euch
um in asien gibt es andere länder sowohl
für lieferanten als auch für abnehmer ja
und auch die regierungen müssen
aufpassen und wo sie denn neue bündnisse
vielleicht finden wir haben wir ja
gesehen sie war dabei als robert habe
gegen katar zum beispiel war und sich
fürchterlich gekriegt hat mit genau
dieser frage
geben und sozusagen von einer diktatur
in jedem fall mittlerweile russland in
die hand einer der regierung von der wir
wissen dass die terrorismus finanziert
und so weiter also die kataris sind ja
nicht der handelspartner das
idealerweise vorstellen die hoffnung von
deutschland aus betrachtet ist natürlich
wir wollen insgesamt unsere
energieversorgung umstellen erneuerbare
energien das ist ja der große plan wir
sind aber längst nicht so weit wo wir
jetzt sein müssten wenn wir annehmen
dass wir eben nicht mehr von russland
weiter die rohstoffe beziehen also nicht
mehr öl und vor allem auch nicht mehr
gas und diese zwischenzeit die können
wir nicht anders überbrücken als uns um
zu schauen wo wir denn das gas her
bekommen man könnte es auch aus den usa
sicher mit flüssiggas erschaffen damen
aber vor ein paar jahren schon mal eine
diskussion gehabt mutter hand trump und
haben gesagt nee dieses schmutzige gas
das mit tracking also aus gestein
herausgelöst
gewonnen wird das wollen wir nicht haben
also die gute lösung die uns wirklich
reinen herzens und reinen gewissen sein
lässt die können wir in jetziger zeit
nicht unbedingt haben das heißt wir
müssen so zu sagen was die moral angeht
jetzt mal ein paar kompromisse machen
wir müssen tempo machen dran bleiben die
ziele tatsächlich zu verwirklichen die
wir wollen dass wir eine andere
energieversorgung bekommen das wir aber
die ganze industrie dafür umstellen
müssen es geht ja nicht nur um die
stromerzeugung oder wie wir heizen
sondern es geht ja auch darum wie unsere
industrie im großen maße befeuert und
mit rohstoffen versorgt wird das ist
großer weg
wenn man dann aber tiefer rein geht in
dieses thema der energieabhängigkeit
dann hat man auf der einen seite
jemanden wie robert habeck der ein sehr
düsteren worten umsätzen auch bei uns
hier in der sendung davor warnt was
passiert und eines der beispiele dafür
ist immer
basf da gibt es einen
vorstandsvorsitzenden herta müller der
auch in sehr drastische art und weise
davor waren was passiert wenn putin
möglicherweise den gashahn zudreht oder
wir ein embargo erklären auf der anderen
seite sind aber genau
dieser konzern und viele andere teil
dieser abhängigkeit teil dieses systems
können sie das mal erklären
wir haben uns in deutschland
einerseits die politik hat sich auf
teilweise naiv bis ignorant verhalten
als es um die energieversorgung und des
zunehmenden abhängig werden von russland
gehen wir haben immer gesagt sie sind
privat wirtschaftliche entscheidungen
wenn eine pipeline gebaut wird wenn eben
noch mehr gas aus russland bezogen wird
wir haben uns auch von
politik aus betrachtet ignorant
gegenüber den warnungen in osteuropa
oder auch kleine anfragen der opposition
damals zum beispiel die grünen bezeugen
anfragen gab es die befragten ihr könnt
euch nicht so abhängig machen ihr könnt
nicht die ganze lieferkette von russland
abhängig machen ihr könnt nicht diese
pipeline bauen diese fragen gab es alles
schon wir haben halt naiv gesagt ja es
ist billig und die haben immer geliefert
wird schon weitergehen
die wirtschaft hat aber umgekehrt auch
sehr bequem
das thema von sich geschoben es war die
billigste variante die politik würde
schon den rest regeln und dann hat eben
auch basf zum beispiel anteile getauscht
mit gastraum dem staatlich gesteuerten
russischen gaskonzern und hat zum
beispiel in den zehn jahren einen
gasspeicher und andere wege der
lieferkette von gas an die russen
angestarrt lich
gesteuerten konzerne verkauft über die
tochter wintershall in dem fall ja
trotzdem können sie das mal erklären was
ist der sinn eines solchen deals ich
glaube dass da im hintergrund ist reden
was wir da sehen dann ist der größte
deutsche gasspeichern wem gehört dieser
größte deutsche gasspeicher er der ist
jetzt unter anderem verwaltung ist jetzt
treuhänderisch ja aber bis vor kurzem
noch das ist unter gazprom leitung am
ende ist es also eine deutsche ist es
ein deutsches unternehmen aber es ist
letztlich von gazprom
die leitungen die da rein laufen wem
gehören die auf deutschem boden die
leitungen die sind vielleicht nicht das
entscheidende aber das wäre sozusagen
das aber alt aber auch die leitungen
selbst die leitungen gehörten gazprom ja
gern zu einem gewissen teil so und das
gas das dadurch läuft kommt auch von
gazprom überraschenderweise mutmaßlich
also es ist ja gerade auch etwas
undurchsichtig dieser speicher ist ja
sehr wenig gefüllt wie weniger als zu
dieser jahreszeit normal wäre sowohl die
markt angemessen als auch unseren
bedürfnissen angemessen und es wird
gemutmaßt lässt sich aber nicht genau
verifizieren dass
ein russisches oder große am ende in
russischem besitz unternehmen sich
gewisse füllstände gesichert hat aber
die nicht befüllt und deshalb bleibt der
speicher leer also ich hab ich habe mir
beeindruckende zahl im hinterkopf wenige
wochen nach ausbruch des krieges ist
dieser größte deutsche gasspeicher zu
genau einem prozent gefüllt also
praktisch leer gas oder
nichtvorhandensein von gas als waffe
konsumenten schon den gesamten herbst
über stellen die behörden fest
da läuft irgendwas schief dass das ding
wirklich richtig gefüllt das heißt die
märkten in deutschland auf deutschem
boden in reden da passiert irgendwas in
diesem gasspeicher und jetzt kommt das
groteske deutsche behörden können aber
nichts tun weil der aus nicht mehr
gehört dafür werden ja jetzt gerade
gesetze geändert
das waren ja warum hat man das so
gemacht also was hatte den basf davon
diese so wichtige deutsche infrastruktur
einfach den russen zu überlassen
einiges getan hat sich im tausch die
zugriffsrechte bei gasfeldern in
russland also das ist entspricht
natürlich auch im interesse eines
unternehmens der basf kriegt sozusagen
gas förderrechte in sibirien und die
russen kriegen dafür deutschen
gasspeicher was sicht eines unternehmens
kann es durchaus sinn ergeben weil die
gesamtversorgung ja nicht aufgabe und
unmittelbares geschäftsinteresse eines
unternehmens sind dafür mal fragen ich
meine sie sagen das ist jetzt das ist
wirtschaft das verstehe ich alles und
wenn irgendwo die markt zu machen ist
dann macht man sie offensichtlich aber
können sie auch mal erklären was da
politisch läuft verstehen sie das also
ich meine doch es gibt auch diese schöne
wort von der kritischen infrastruktur
ist doch kritische infrastruktur davon
hängt doch unglaublich viel ab in diesem
land das so abhängig ist von energie die
viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt wie
kann man denn dann nach allem was
passiert ist zwar um 2015 herum ist das
alles über die bühne gegangen ein jahr
nach der krim wie kann man das in die
hände dieser leute geben
es gibt zwei ebenen also die
bundesregierung namentlich auch der
damalige wirtschaftsminister sigmar
gabriel haben sich darauf zurückgezogen
unsere energieversorgung der
energiemarkt wurde von der eu insgesamt
liberalisiert und wir haben das eben
durchgesetzt das war dann auch
politische linie wir wollten dass der
markt herrscht man kann aber schon
damals sagen wir wollen aber nicht dass
ein kartell herrscht oder eine
marktbeherrschende stellung zu jemand
ausnützt was damals eben auch schon
kritisiert und gesehen wurde die grünen
zum beispiel an das klar kritisiert gab
auch noch andere jahre da und dann gibt
es aber eben noch dieses spezielle was
die energieversorgung eben auszeichnet
es ist ja schon im allgemeinen interesse
weil unsere industriegesellschaft weil
jeder und jede einzelne davon abhängen
also muss man auch rahmenbedingungen
schaffen dass gewisse sicherungen
eingezogen werden das ist eben nicht mal
kurz zwei wochen keine energie gibt
sowie werden irgendwie im
supermarktregal meister gefehlt
haben sie eine erklärung dafür wird
gleich über getragen sprechen also
schauen wir uns doch an wie viele
führende europäische spitzenpolitiker
noch kurz vor dem ausbruch des krieges
in der ukraine für genau diese betriebe
gearbeitet haben also russische
staatliche betriebe ein ehemaliger
französischer premierminister eine
ehemalige italienische premierminister
ein ehemaliger deutscher bundeskanzler
zwei ehemalige österreichische
bundeskanzler
hier wurde im großen rahmen
neben diesen markt wird also neben
diesen wirtschaftlichen strategien auch
investiert in ja dass die abhängigkeiten
würden geschaffen nachdem diese
politiker die aktiv die politik
verlassen und wir reden über herrn
faymann wir reden nein wir reden über
christian kern wolfgang schüssel
francois für jo ok matteo renzi und
natürlich gerhard schröder und das sind
die bekanntesten das waren immerhin die
und wir reden ja von einigen der
g7-staaten einige der größten
volkswirtschaften der welt wo politiker
nach ihrer aktiven laufbahn für
russische firmen in den in den in den
führenden stellen angestellt werden als
signal auch an natürlich andere das ist
ja auch immer ein signal ach ja wenn man
also eine gewisse art von politik
macht gibt es immer die möglichkeit am
ende hier angestellt zu werden ich weiß
es gibt viele politiker die haben das
sich natürlich nicht so vorführen lassen
aber das interesse der russischen
politik und dieser betriebe die ja teil
dieses machtapparates sind hier
abhängigkeiten politische abhängigkeiten
zu schaffen menschen auf ihre seite zu
ziehen die dann wiederum ganz viele
kontakte haben kinder in die parteien
und regierungen von unseren demokratien
das ist ja kein zufall gewesen